And the Game of the Year award goes to Sekiro.
Tonight, Sekiro: Shadows Die Twice also wins best action-adventure game.
He's very moved.
So, Sekiro has a lot of difficult and complex elements...
...that made us a little unsure when it was about to come out...
...and we were both surprised and overjoyed at the reaction that we saw.
So I'd like to share the joy of receiving this award with the staff at FromSoftware...
...who pulled out all the stops to make it happen,...
...as well as the team in Activision for their ongoing support throughout.
And finally, I'd like to give out a huge thank you to our players.
We couldn't have done it without you and it was a huge honor to make.
So we will continue to try and make the best games as we possibly can.